in the science of screenwriting what's
your favorite chapter or maybe a chapter
that was most challenging that you felt
very proud of I I think my favorite
chapter is chapter one because we got to
give kind of the overview of the dance
we were gonna try to do for the
potential screenwriter or anyone really
who's interested in why movies are so
fascinating why human beings will go
into a dark place with dozens of total
strangers and sit quietly for hours and
that behavior alone is you know worth a
good thorough psychological
investigation so in Chapter one I think
we had a lot of fun building up what we
were going to do in the rest of the book
but I like the chapter that's on the
creative stages of the screenwriter
that's a chapter that involved quite a
bit of research in studying how the
creative process itself plays out in in
any artist in any creative act but in
screenwriting the importance of the
story itself so you had asked Paul a
question about yes or no if you focus on
the audience would that make your screen
write your screenplay a success my
answer would be a flat out no flat out
no you you must have the story the story
is what will make your screen play a
success the ability to pace your story
to weave your story to tell your story
in a way that's respectful even playful
with the human brain that's going to be
processing it that will give your story
the the attraction and the further
success but without the story you can
play people all you want it's you know
if you don't have something to tell them
they're there no reason to engage
and in the chapter on the creative
processes the stages of creativity I got
to do quite a bit of research on what we
know about creativity creativity is
considered the ultimate cognitive
process so we do all these things in our
brains right we we pay attention we
perceive all of our different sensory
activities happen in the brain so you
don't see with your eyes you see with
your occipital lobe
you don't hear with your ears you hear
with your auditory cortex so all of
these amazing things has happen in the
brain but they happen in parallel
processing simultaneous imal taneous lee
so you're hearing and seeing while
you're thinking about what you're
hearing and seeing while you're
remembering what you've seen and heard
while you're predicting what make so our
brains are these beautiful
orchestrations of simultaneous processes
and creativity emerges from that unique
totally individual no two brains do
anything exactly alike so I think that's
my favorite chapter it was a lot of fun
to explore what helps creativity what
hinders creativity and what the
screenwriter can use to get over slumps
you know used to break through blocks so
that was my favorite I think thinking of
your favorite films are you able to look
at it from another perspective and see
why see the science behind why you like
certain films sometimes rarely I'm a
devotee of stories I love going to
movies and I don't pretend to be a
scientist I'm just a movie watcher in
there there I can train myself you know
to take
like Paul does take clips sequences and
then I can take apart pieces of movie
but if I'm given an opportunity to be
told the story I take it storytelling is
it's the human gift
there are as far as we know no other
vertebrate animals that engage in
fantasy that engage in storytelling
it makes us uniquely human and from my
perspective it's this connection to
language which as I was saying is begun
before birth we we listened in utero for
that voice that is closest to us so the
person carrying us is the most important
voice that we hear and I think that I
don't know it's magic to me and I'm a
scientist I'm all about data but it is
magic to me
that we communicate at all that we get
each other even you know vaguely and
that we do it so effortlessly and so
successfully the gift of language the
gift of storytelling is what I've taught
for decades and it's still just a
magical mystery tour it's amazing how we
don't run out of language we don't run
out of stories
yeah boy meets girl or you know these
kinds of repetitive plots but each and
every movie about boy beats girl
captures us as an audience holds us we
are as if we've never seen the whole
scenario before that's a good movie
right the the ones that don't make it
are the ones that have not
enough of that individual creativity to
the storytelling so even language if
it's not our native language we can
still relate you know how people love
seeing foreign films is there something
different about that or that's a great
question and I love talking about when
so as if you were deaf as if you did not
have auditory processing and so you were
fault and following along closed caption
you're reading the subtitles you still
get all the emotion that's portrayed
visually but there's a lot of data that
suggests the sound not just the language
but including the language but the
background music the tension sounds the
relaxing sounds the auditory cues that a
screenwriter adds to their film to
create that emotional mood when those
are missing the movie is much more
intellectual process and much less of a
you know full-body emotional I'm in this
story so watching foreign films takes a
different mindset when you go to watch a
foreign film you and you know you're
going to be watching the the subtitles
to get the dialogue if you're a hearing
person and you can still have the
background cues to what's going on it's
much more successful for people who have
auditory disabilities there it's movie
watching is an entirely different
experience